et pour en parler nous sommes avec yves
d'amécourt maire sortant de sauveterre
de guyenne conseiller régional l'est
républicain de la nouvelle aquitaine et
vice-président de 50 millions
d'électeurs bonsoir yves d'amécourt
merci des droits sur rt france que
pensez vous de cette date du 28 juin
pour commencer c'est une date qui est
très risqué parce que en fait on n'a
aucune certitude sur la façon dont se
comportera le virus le 28 juin et donc
le gouvernement a déjà fait d'erreur
d'organiser le premier tour le 15 mars
il renouvelle son erreur en voulant
organiser le le second tour le 28 juin
aujourd'hui les maires sont complètement
accaparé par la gestion de la crise par
le confinement puis par le déconfinement
aujourd'hui il faut relancer l'économie
et au lieu de se consacrer à ces deux
tâches importantes pour le pays
eh bien les maires vont rentrer en
campagne électorale et s'occuper d'autre
chose
c'est donc à mon avis une triple erreur
d'autant que la campagne on l'a entendu
de la bouche de christophe castaner va
durer un mois au lieu de cinq jours
habituellement et forcément c'est une
campagne qui va changer de méthode
elle va changer de méthode elle va être
elle va exclure un certain nombre de
français de la campagne puisque le
conseil scientifique demande une
campagne numérique
or la fracture numérique existe en
france et un certain nombre de français
qui n'ont pas accès aux outils
numériques est donc le premier tour
avait été un scrutin sanitaires et avait
déjà rompu le pacte républicain autour
du suffrage universel et cette fois ci
on va le rompre une deuxième fois en ne
faisant campagne qu'auprès d'une seule
une petite partie des français ceux qui
ne sont pas victimes de la fracture
numérique est ce que vous pensez qu'il
ya une fracture également en termes de
risque puisqu'on sait qu'il ya toujours
des zones rouges et des zones vertes
c'est le cas aussi ces problématiques
pour la tenue de ce scrutin vous pensez
bien sûr je pense que là au premier tour
on a perdu 30 % de l'électorat habituel
des élections municipales il est
probable qu'au deuxième tour il ya
encore moins d'électeurs et ce sera très
compliqué pour les gens de
l'est et les gens de l'île de france de
se rendre dans les bureaux de vote le 28
juin à l'oeil a aucune garantie sur sur
le fait que le couronne un virus le 28
juin soit stoppée c'est bien pour ça que
le conseil scientifique devrait se
prononcer quinze jours auparavant
il reste encore une petite marge de
manoeuvre vous pensez pas vous savez
déjà le conseil scientifique dans son
rapport de 16 pages quand le
gouvernement dit qu'il ya un accord de
principe du conseil scientifique
quand on lit le rapport de 16 pages
prend on prend peur et on comprend pas
bien où est ce que le gouvernement un
abus a vu un avis favorable
et donc il ya un risque sanitaire
et puis un risque démocratique très fort
le risque que ce scrutin soit en rupture
avec les fondations de la république
avec la constitution qui garantit un
suffrage universel libre égal pour tous
les les électeurs ce qui ne sera pas le
cas le 28 juin
donc vous pensez qu'il aurait fallu
reporter ce scrutin à plus tard à
octobre ou à 2021 mais dans ce cas là il
aurait fallu refaire les deux tours
absolument c'est ce que nous pensons
dans l'association 50 millions
d'électeurs
d'ailleurs demain nous allons déposer un
référé liberté auprès du conseil d'état
pour faire en sorte que le conseil
d'état puisse se positionner sur cette
proposition du premier ministre cette
décision du premier ministre et notre
référé liberté sera assorti d'une
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité parce que depuis huit
semaines
on fait beaucoup de choses dans notre
pays et on ne consulte jamais le conseil
constitutionnel il semble qu'aujourd'hui
serait important de consulter le conseil
constitutionnel avant de d'organiser une
démocratie au rabais et vous êtes de
ceux qui avaient voté déjà le budget de
votre commune c'est pas le cas de toutes
les communes vous comprenez qu'il ya
aussi urgence pour le faire et pouvoir
faire avancer les projets aujourd'hui
d'abord les communes peuvent voter leurs
budgets
elles peuvent le faire avec des outils
par correspondance moi j'ai voté le
budget par correspondance le budget de
la communauté des communes
le budget de la commune nous l'avions
voté avant les élections par mesure de
prudence
aujourd'hui on peut voter les budgets et
les ordonnances du premier ministe
permettent d'en
alger les dépenses d'investissement et
de fonctionnement et donc il faut
absolument d'ailleurs c'est c'est le
pacte républicain de passer les
commandes de passer les marchés publics
de passer des appels d'offres et ça on
peut très bien le faire en utilisant les
moyens qui sont à notre disposition dans
les ordonnances du premier ministre
notamment le vote par correspondance les
réunions comme nous le faisons ce soir
avec vous par par skype
mais dans nos zones rurales tout le
monde n'est pas équipé d'internet tout
le monde n'a pas accès à internet par
contre tout le monde a accès à la poste
au papier au crayon et donc il faut
trouver faire preuve d'imagination mais
on peut faire beaucoup de choses
oui quand la poste fonctionne
normalement puisque là aussi il y a des
carences dans certaines certains
territoires
le fait que l'on en entende edouard
philippe dire je sais pouvoir compter
sur les mers christophe castaner le dit
aussi
c'est vous qui allez être qui allaitent
chargé de deux du côté sanitaire de
fournir des masques de fournir du gel
hydroalcoolique enfin que tout soit en
place pour qu'il n'y ait aucun risque
c'est ce que nous faisons déjà depuis
quelques semaines et donc c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que je trouve
incompréhensible qu'aujourd'hui on dise
au mr on a besoin de vous pour gérer la
crise mais d'un autre côté on va vous
demander de rentrer en campagne
électorale il faut s'occuper d'autre
chose et donc tout ça et pas du tout
cohérent
la chose la plus cohérente aurait été de
choisir janvier 2021 pour organiser les
deux tours de l'élection de prolonger le
mandat des maires pour que les équipes
en place gère la crise du corps de virus
gère la crise économique et le rôle de
la relance de l'économie qui va suivre
et puis se préoccupe aussi de la crise
sociale qui va suivre parce que on n'en
parle pas beaucoup aujourd'hui mais il
ya beaucoup de désastre économique dans
nos chez nos commerçants chez nos
artisans chez nos hôteliers nos
restaurateurs
on va attaquer la période touristique et
donc il est important que les équipes en
place soit à l'oeuvre au lieu de se
préoccuper des élections si votre
reportage d'ailleurs à ce titre était
très instructif sur ce qu'en pensent les
français
c'est mitigé en c'est vrai je vous la
corde yves d'amécourt dernière question
s'il
le scrutin avait été reporté à plus tard
et les deux tours devait être refait on
aurait accusé l'exécutif de vouloir
rejouer à ce que disent un peu les uns
et les autres si vous voulez toute façon
toutes les solutions sont mauvaises mais
parmi les mauvaises
il faut choisir la meilleure l'exécutif
al'avantage de ne pas avoir beaucoup
d'élus donc il peut prendre ces choses
là avec recul puisqu'il a pas il a pas
début et qu'il n'y a pas tellement dans
le jeu pour l'exécutif puisqu'il n'y a
pas tellement de personnes qui portent
l'étiquette de la majorité aujourd'hui
dans les élections municipales
clairement donc si le conseil d'état ne
vous donne pas raison vous allez
organiser les élections et on prend la
responsabilité ou pas de toute façon les
maires sont les hussards de la
république donc ils sont aux ordres du
préfet le maire il a trois casquettes il
est le représentant de ses habitants il
est le président du conseil municipal
mais il est aussi le représentant du
préfet dans sa commune et le
représentant de l'état et donc il est
aux ordres sur cette activité
d'organiser les élections et donc si un
maire ne veut pas organiser les
élections mais il laisse son siège il
démissionne et le confier à quelqu'un
d'autre
merci beaucoup et yves d'amécourt
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur arte
france